oui moi je savais pas parce que c'est
l'application je mets pas les animaux
que je suis allergique
monsieur et non voyant ou pas c'est ça
les moi je suis choqué que je reviens
avec des téléphones et en train de
filmer et après il présentait que il
était avec il était malvoyant voilà je
suis choqué vous voyez avec un chien où
il y a marqué chien aveugle là vous
voyez que c'est un aveugle moi j'ai
trouvé quoi vous voulez pas le prendre
avec le chien pourquoi moi je suis
allergique il a commencé en fait si vous
avez toutes les questions sauf les
insultes racistes donc
on les a entendu on les a vu il y a eu
retourne dans ton pays etc
pour les animaux
tu le vois en commander un pour toi
[Musique]